you might find this interesting the U.S
opened was over the weekend you might
have heard about that and uh guess who
was advertising and sponsoring the U.S
open with their shot of the day segment
shot of the day the ball of these people
take a look
we'll take you to the modernist shot of
the day and it was
saving the match point of the match
point to get to number 24. there were a
lot of shots that were highly impactful
but here's the final one
[Music]
thank you
another day at the office
[Applause]
relief and release there
so the shot of the day brought to you by
moderna shot of the day brought to you
by moderna like they're still doing it
guys right you'll see how I'm connecting
this to the war thing but they're still
doing it the shot of the day just like
we've shown you all those videos of
Pfizer who sponsors all of the media
that you know sort of the NPC people are
watching right you turn on CNN you turn
on ABC News NBC News and it's always
brought to you by Pfizer uh well the guy
they showed there during the shot of the
day that was Novak Djokovic and uh yeah
he won the U.S open so I thought we'd
show you that
yeah
24 and Counting
24 and he still wants more
that's who he is
foreign
twist guys novik Djokovic who now is
widely thought as the greatest tennis
player in the history of the sport 24
Grand Slam championships uh you may
remember that he was not allowed to
compete in the U.S for over two years he
was not allowed to compete in the
Australian Open a couple years ago
because yeah he is unfaxed so suck that
moderna you might remember this from
February of 22 this was a BBC reporter
asking him if it was worth it to not get
faxed I understand the consequences of
my decision and one of the consequences
of my decision was not going to
Australia and I was prepared not to go
and I understand that not being
vaccinated today I you know I'm unable
to travel to most of the tournaments at
the moment and that's the price you're
willing to pay that that is the price
that I'm willing to pay ultimately
are you prepared to forgo
the chance to be the greatest player
that ever picked up a racket
statistically
because you feel so strongly about this
Jab
yes
I do but as things stand
If this means that you miss the French
Open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes that is the price that I'm willing
to pay and if it means that you miss
Wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay yes
why no fact why why because the
principles of uh
decision making on my body are more
important than any title
or anything else
I'm I'm trying to be in tune with my
body
um as much as I possibly can
I don't know who that journalist air
quotes journalist is but what a pathetic
embarrassing hack what a sycophant for
the machine and we know literally
hundreds of these types of people that
operate in mainstream media but what a
beautiful answer I have some autonomy
over my body I will make decisions for
myself if you watch the extended portion
of the interview he talks about his diet
he talks about his exercise regimen
um and guess what he turned out to be
right